For centuries
we've been fighting and keeping track of
different things that move in and out of
this world
the most dangerous ones we find a way to
contain
this is one of the worst ever
mom can you hear me
i had a man speak with my mother i am mother
this family's unnatural behavior
i've never experienced anything like it
what happened to them it wasn't some
random family tragedy
their father was evil
and mother cursed him for discovering the truth
there are other forces that play here
a demon so powerful he could wipe
out all of mankind
we can't do this alone should we put
them together now
there will be blow back
please tell me that she's dead
you come crawling back
looking for mommy's love
the last thing the world needs
is a helstrom family reunion
Welcome back everyone this is going to
be my new marble helstrom trailer
doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness
easter eggs ghost rider
all the really crazy supernatural dark
stuff that marvel was working on in
marvel phase four in marvel phase five
so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos
we'll do a new amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what kind of really dark
team-up you want them to do with
marvel's supernatural characters during
marvel phase 4
marvel phase 5. so if you don't know
what's going on with helstrom this is a
limited series it's only going to be one
season it's the final tv show that
marvel did under
jeff loeb and marvel tv before they sort
of reorganized things with kevin feige
and he started pumping out all the
disney plus marvel avengers spin-offs
the show is sort of a cross between
rosemary's baby in the omen series
damon helstrom is the son of marvel's
version of the devil
so in the series as you can see he's
sort of like a supernatural detective
like john constantine from the dc
universe and if you haven't spent a lot
of time reading those classic marvel
comics that deal with ghostwriter and
their darker
characters marvel's version of the devil
is not mephisto
mephisto is a version of a marvel devil
but he's not the devil in this context
he's just one of the many different
cosmic fear lords from other dimensions
in the marvel universe we'll get into
that when we start talking about doctor
strange 2 multiverse of madness stuff
the way marvel explains heaven hell is
really just other dimensions
in the marvel universe but there are
different tiers of gods
in the marvel universe like you have the
sky fathers you have people like odin
the way they integrate that into the mcu
is a little bit different than what they
do with those characters in the comics
but it's not quite as complicated as it
seems the doctor strange movies are the
best explanation for that
think multiverse of madness multiverse
alternate dimensions
alternate realities alternate universes
but the helstrom character does have a
deep connection to dr strange he was a
member of his defenders team at one
point he was a member of the midnight
suns which is where you get into big
ghost rider crossover
the partner that he's talking to in the
trailer footage is his sister
her name is satana i think they just
call her anna during a lot of this
footage
but both he and she have the same type
of divine supernatural magical powers
because of their devil bloodline
marvel's introducing blade into the mcu
vampires doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness is going to be the first real
mcu horror movie they're doing a moon
knight disney plus series he's a really
dark character if you're not familiar
with him
so marvel is just doing a lot more
darker supernatural characters heading
into marvel phase 4 and this is just the
beginning
kevin feige said way back during marvel
phase one they were looking for a path
to a lot of these darker characters like
blade and ghost rider but they just
didn't know how to get there until they
did doctor strange and he was the route
to that
the reason why this show went to hulu
instead of disney plus though
is because it was part of a larger ghost
rider supernatural marvel crossover
event that they were going to build up
to
a while ago involving the ghost rider tv
show that they had been developing
that's right there was a ghost rider tv
show that they were almost about to make
with gabrielle luna's version of
ghostwriter
from agents of shield the big crossover
event was going to be their next version
of the marvel netflix defenders team
like with daredevil luke cage jessica
jones iron fist all coming together
although the punisher was part of that
he wasn't really a defender's character
now that disney owns hulu that's just
where a lot of their crazier content
that they don't want to put on disney
plus goes so that's why this super dark
midnight sun style big crossover event
was going to go on that
they were going to call the team up
adventure into fear and it would have
just run for multiple seasons it would
have been the same model as the marvel
netflix shows where you do
individual shows but then they all cross
over in a team up show
some of those shows got cancelled in the
last year because they sort of
reorganized the way they make marvel tv
shows now kevin feige is in charge of
everything creative that marvel does
he's in charge of the tv shows the
movies
and marvel comics if you can believe it
he just has a lot of oversight over
marvel comics it's not like he makes
every single marvel comic book he just
sort of informs the overall direction
that they're headed with that stuff
but the idea with giving him control of
all the tv shows is that there's just a
lot more consistency and a lot more
crossover and synergy with the movies
when they say everything is connected
they kind of started out with agents of
shield
now they really mean it now there
actually is genuine crossover like we
just got a wandivision trailer
that is truly connected to the movies
and will inform marvel phase 4
future movies we'll see those episodes
later this year thankfully
this helstrom tv show is just one of
the few shows that survived the merger
between marvel tv and marvel studios
when kevin feige took over
so they fired jeff loeb in a lot of the
shows that he was developing they got
rid of
including that gabriel luna robbie reyes
ghost rider tv show from agents of
shield
but the basic premise of the helstrom
show is they're sort of building it is a
x-file style
possession procedural where they go
around looking at demons that possess
people trying to get rid of them
and they find out that one of the worst
demons of all time has come to earth
again no surprise that demon winds up
being helstrom's true father who is the
marvel version of the devil
that's why you see all that footage of
the person sitting in the throne with
blood running down their hand
just implying that he is king of demons
they purposefully hide a lot of the
footage of his face so that you don't
see who it actually is like they scratch
it out in that family picture there
but the way they talk about the father
during the trailer just implies that at
some point he was banished back to hell
and when they refer to the mother
unleashing something new on the world
again in present day
you start to see all this violence
erupting all these demons proliferating
they're just teasing he has returned to
earth and helstrom and his sister satan
are gonna try and lock him back in hell
he has crazy magical aptitude
and his innate divine power is just
immense so doctor strange
at one point actually considered him as
a potential successor
for sorcerer's supreme they haven't said
much about the future of potential
midnight suns or hearts of darkness
crossover on the marvel disney plush
shows but i think a lot of that will
happen
probably after they do the blade movie
they haven't said when that's going to
happen now and because so many marvel
movies have been delayed in the past
year but i think they'll start talking
more about it when they do the actual
moon knight series
there have been a bunch of announcements
about castings for say like she-hulk and
the miss marvel tv
show moon knight is going to happen
right after those originally they were
going to release doctor strange 2
multiverse of madness march 2022
that might get pushed just a little bit
again because they just delayed the
marvel movies one more time
this morning as i'm making this video
there was a big announcement of course
i'll do a separate video about that
because there's a whole bunch of marvel
news today but i think the really
exciting thing with a marvel horror
stuff that they're doing in the movies
now starting with doctor strange too is
that they brought sam raimi back so not
only is he a notable
spider-man director so sort of bringing
it full circle
because kevin feige himself was a
producer on those sam raimi spider-man
films
but he's also a notable horror director
there have been all kinds of rumors
about crazy cameos and alternate
versions of avengers characters there
was even a rumor about an iron man cameo
scene but it was going to be the tom
cruise version of iron man that marvel
was originally going to do back in the
late 90s
no joke before robert downey jr became
iron man in 2008 in that first iron man
movie
marvel tried to make an iron man movie
in the late 90s with tom cruise as tony
stark iron man
because robert downey jr is so fantastic
i think we can say now that that version
probably would have been inferior
to robert downey jr's iron man so i am
happy with the way things wound up but
it would be crazy if that winds up
coming true
but it's just a rumor at this point so
if we hear any more news about crazy
cameos from alternate versions of
avengers of course i'll do a video about
it
all the helstrom episodes are going to
start releasing on october 16th i don't
have big plans to do
videos for weekly episodes but i might
do a wrap up after the series is done
i think the takeaway in all this is just
to get really hyped up about super dark
supernatural characters
coming into the mcu slowly in other
marvel tv news
they just dropped that wandivision
trailer i'll post a link at the end of
this but they also announced that falcon
and winter soldier had been delayed
so i'll talk more about when different
marvel series and movies are coming when
i do a video either later tonight or
tomorrow so as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see
that when i post it
everyone click here for that full
avengers wandivision trailer video
and click here for that brand new star
wars the mandalorian season 2
trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!